>> It's my pleasure today
to welcome Peter,
Bjorn, and John
in their only Bay Area appearance.
[clapping and cheering]
I'd like to introduce
Peter Moren on guitar,
Bjorn Yttling on...
>> PETER: That's Bjorn.
>> BJORN: We changed places.
>> You changed places.
Okay. Sorry.
Bjorn on guitar and
Peter on keyboards.
But John is still on drum
and percussion like objects.
Excellent.
So the trio that we're
about to enjoy today
were formed in
Stockholm back in '99
and as I hear it were
influenced by the sounds
of classic '60s baroque,
pop, power pop,
and new wave,
but these guys
aren't revivalists.
Instead, they've created
some of the most exciting
and original Indie rock
of the new millennium.
The band began playing
gigs soon after forming
and quickly began a
period of compilations
alongside artists like
Sahara Hotnights,
Badly Drawn Boy,
and Holiday for Strings.
After releasing a few singles,
they released their self-titled
first album in 2002
on the tiny
Beat that Label.
After a few more shows
and singles and an EP,
the group jumped to the
plankanomy [ph] label in 2004
and released Beats, Straps,
and Backgrounds EP.
It was soon followed by the
wonderful 2004 full length
released Falling Out
and then by Writer's
Block a year later.
The trio's fifth
album Living Things,
offers more of what
made young folks
and international hipster
anthem, infectious,
electro-acoustic tunes,
framing tales of romance
and its just contents,
without further ado,
let's here from Peter,
Bjorn,
and John.
[clapping]
>> BJORN: ♪ Negative,
♪ why always so negative?
♪ If you have problems,
♪ why don't you go solve them?
♪ Beat me up.
♪ At least you won't
be out of touch.
♪ If you're such a poet,
♪ loose your tongue and show it.
♪ Do this thing,
♪ this type of thing.
♪ Put a little money
in this type of thing.
♪ I've got nothing
to worry about.
♪ Do this thing,
♪ this type of thing.
♪ Put a little money
in this type of thing.
♪ I've got nothing
to worry about.
♪ Trouble seems,
♪ trouble seems to follow you.
♪ It's always around you like
some thing you subscribe to.
♪ Be prepared,
♪ there must be something
in you turning boys to men
♪ and then back again,
♪ back again.
♪ Do this thing,
♪ this type of thing.
♪ Put a little money in
this type of thing.
♪ I've got nothing
to worry about.
♪ Do this thing,
♪ this type of thing.
♪ Put a little money
in this type of thing.
♪ I've got nothing
to worry about.
♪ Do this thing,
♪ this type of thing.
♪ Put a little money
in this type of thing.
♪ I've got nothing
to worry about.
♪ Do this thing,
♪ this type of thing.
♪ Put a little money
in this type of thing.
♪ I've got nothing
to worry about.
to worry about,
♪ nothing to worry about.
[clapping]
>> BJORN: Thank you.
>> PETER: So we're going to
continue with some new songs
from the latest album,
hope that's fine with you.
>> BJORN: Yeah.
This song here.
>> PETER: ♪ Tell me how
do I get to know you.
♪ You untie me as if
I were a shoelace.
♪ You let out all I can
hold between my buttons,
♪ but from you I get nothing.
♪ Even if I gave you
a mountain on a bad day
♪ you don't think you
were at the top of it.
♪ And how can I change that
when it's in your fundament.
♪ You can't take a compliment.
♪ Take a rest with me,
♪ after a long day.
♪ Foot's on the table.
♪ Don't take it down,
♪ down, down.
♪ Don't take them down.
♪ Is it your parents
♪ or it's the past?
♪ La,
♪ la, la, la,
♪ la, la, la, la.
♪ If you should reach
what you aim for,
♪ don't give yourself
the blame for
♪ what's obviously
not your fault.
♪ Don't laugh this away.
♪ You won't get to hear
what I really have to say.
♪ What I see is not
what you think I see
♪ and what I think is not
what you think I think.
♪ I know me but you don't know
me as I don't know you.
♪ Take a rest with me,
♪ after a long day.
♪ Foot's on the table,
♪ don't take it down,
down, down.
♪ Don't take them down.
♪ Is it your parents
♪ or just the past?
♪ or it's the past?
♪ Is it your parents
♪ or it's the past,
or it's the past,
♪ or it's the...
♪ La,
♪ la, la, la,
♪ la, la, la, la,
♪ la,
♪ la, la, la,
♪ la, la, la, la.♪
Feel free to join in,
it's very easy.
♪ La,
♪ la, la, la,
♪ la, la, la, la,
One more time.
Lunch time sing-along.
Come on.
>> ALL: ♪ La,
la, la, la,
la, la, la, la.
[clapping]
>> PETER: Okay.
This is the new single.
>> JOHN: Okay.
And four, three, two....
>> PETER: ♪ Please put just
these books and magazines away
♪ 'cause they don't
move me no more.
♪ They don't move me no more.
♪ Put them all away.
♪ Forget photos and letters,
all people that matter.
♪ They don't move
me no more.
♪ You don't move me no more
and I don't even mind.
♪ It's surprisin' how rapidly
♪ we were changing
from you and me.
♪ No matter how you count,
no, no,
♪ it will go to show.
♪ When history is done
♪ and everything is over
♪ just to keep us warm,
♪ it's slowly getting colder,
♪ it's hard to stay the same.
♪ You had to go away.
♪ History is done
♪ and everything is gone.
♪ Early morning and late night,
♪ going over the same fight
don't move me no more.
♪ You don't move me no more
♪ and I don't even mind.
♪ All these things that I keep
when I cared too deep
♪ gonna put it to sleep.
♪ I can run much faster when
nothing weighs me down.
♪ We can change what
has been before.
♪ It's erasing you
can't restore.
♪ Let the scraping
back go, go,
♪ I don't want it back.
♪ When history is done
and everything is over,
♪ just to keep us warm,
♪ it's slowly getting colder.
♪ It's hard to stay the same,
♪ you had to go away.
♪ History is done
♪ and everything is gone.
♪ Everything is gone.
[clapping]
>> BJORN: Thank you so much.
Do you want us to talk more?
Then, you think you
should ask these two.
>> PETER: Oh, yeah.
>> BJORN: Come up and
ask something. John?
Or ask from there.
What's your first question?
Yeah, take it back.
No questions.
[laugher]
Next question.
>> JOHN: Yeah. The first
record was like ketchup;
the second one was
like dark chocolates;
third one was like beer;
and the one previous
to this one
was an instrumental
record that was like--
what was that?
Ketchup mixed with
chocolate or something.
And this new one is what
flavor is that, Peter?
>> PETER: Marshmallows.
>> JOHN: Yeah.
Okay.
>> BJORN: Thank you.
>> PETER: Yeah, we're going to do the title track of the album.
And since we were supposed
to talk, we forgot about that.
I had a lot of things to say
earlier but I didn't know
how I was supposed to talk.
Usually, we're not
supposed to talk
because we never
had time to talk.
>> BJORN: This is talking, huh. >> So talk.
>> PETER: Like in the old days
we used to do like 90% talking
and some playing,
but now we got
used to just play
and--anyway, I can say
something about this song,
this is called Living Thing.
It's the title track
of the new album
and there's a couple of reasons
why it is the title track.
One of them is very simple,
because all our albums,
apart from the very first one
which is called Peter,
Bjorn, and John
which is a good name
for an album,
all the other ones have had
two words and three spellings,
so the second was Falling Out
and then came Writer's Block,
Seaside Rock,
Living Thing.
So, it's all very clever.
It's going to continue
like that.
Let's see what we can
come up with next time.
>> BJORN: I've been playing
this for the sound
and that's a center [ph] pad
and that's a guitar.
>> JOHN: Guitar.
I think the next one is going to
be called a Google Map.
>> PETER: Yes.
Google Earth.
>> JOHN: Google Earth.
>> PETER: But it's also a song
that it's kind of about the band
which is, you know,
it's three people that
when they come together
they become a monster
rather than three
separate persons.
So, it's like a blob
that you can't control.
It just takes over and explodes
and weird things happen.
So, it's like a different organism
to Peter, Bjorn, and John,
the persons,
the band, it's like
a living thing.
Yeah.
That's what the song is
about the band. Okay.
>> JOHN: Okay.
>> PETER: ♪ Drop the funny line,
♪ it's not funny anymore.
♪ Make me feel at home like
you used to do before.
♪ Fill another glass if
it makes you more at ease.
♪ I could easily act.
♪ I usually aim to please.
♪ I've grown accustomed
to grow old.
♪ It suits me fine,
just fine.
♪ Stop wasting my precious time.
♪ From now on it's just mine.
♪ I'm rented by the hour.
♪ And if you can't
afford to pay,
you gotta keep me bothered,
oh, you gotta keep me awake.
PETER BJORN AND JOHN:♪ You don't have to look me in the eye.
You don't have to look me
in the eye no more.
You don't have to look
me in the eye.
You don't have to love me.
♪ It's a living thing,
it's a living thing,
♪ it's a living thing.
♪ It's a terrible thing
to lose a thing.
♪ It's a living thing,
♪ it's a living thing.
♪ It's terrible thing
to lose a thing.
♪ It's a living thing,
♪ it's a living thing.
♪ It's a terrible thing
to lose a thing.
♪ It's a living thing,
♪ it's a living thing,
♪ It's a terrible thing to lose.
>> PETER: ♪ We didn't
do it together,
♪ and now is it too late?
♪ It's pretty tight
around the corners
♪ and I no longer
have your taste.
♪ What is it about a friendship
♪ that always keeps
the closet closed?
♪ But I can tell
it's dusty in here,
♪ so I don't even want
to think about yours.
PETER BJORN AND JOHN:♪ You don't have to look me in the eye.
♪ You don't have to look
me in the eye no more.
♪ You don't have to
look me in the eye.
♪ You don't have to love me.
♪ It's a living thing,
♪ it's a living thing,
♪ it's a living thing.
♪ It's a terrible thing
to lose a thing.
♪ It's a living thing,
♪ it's a living thing.
♪ It's a terrible thing
to lose a thing.
♪ It's a living thing,
♪ it's a living thing,
♪ It's terrible thing
to lose a thing.
♪ It's a living thing,
♪ it's a living.
♪ It's a terrible
thing to lose.
♪ It's a living thing,
♪ it's a living thing.
♪ It's a terrible
thing to lose.
♪ It's a living thing,
♪ it's a living thing.
♪ It's a terrible thing
to lose a thing.
♪ It's a living thing,
♪ it's a living thing.
♪ It's a terrible thing
to lose a thing.
♪ It's a living thing,
♪ it's a living thing.
♪ It's a terrible thing
to lose a thing.
[clapping]
>> BJORN: Thank you so much.
>> PETER: Okay. We can say something about the next song.
This is the single
in Australia.
>> Talk about something else.
>> PETER: Okay. I think
a single in Germany.
Okay.
First, it's the same single.
You can always kind
of make up stories,
they don't know.
>> No, but what's going on.
PETER:We're going to do a song called 100 Meters of Hurdles,
which is a very good song
from our first record.
And we never play that because no one likes it, for me--
so, we don't know
how to play too.
>> BJORN: I do.
>> PETER: Yeah, good.
I think we should do
this German single.
>> JOHN: Okay.
>> PETER: Australian single.
>> BJORN: Okay.
All right.
>> PETER: And the reason it's
not a single anywhere else
is because it's got cursing
and swearing in it,
and that you don't want that
on the radio in America
and not in the U.K. either,
but in Australia it's fine.
It's great.
So,
but I think we can
curse on Google or...
>> JOHN: Can we do that?
>> PETER: Yeah.
>> JOHN: Okay.
>> BJORN: Yeah.
It is called Lay It Down.
>> PETER: ♪ You sure
can get it up.
♪ At least that's what you say.
♪ You don't know how to stop.
♪ You just can't walk away.
♪ And when you saw her face,
♪ you said she's something else.
♪ I know you just can't wait.
♪ This more than I can take.
♪ You just can't lay it down.
♪ You're just gonna
lay her down.
>> PETER and JOHN: ♪ Hey,
shut the fuck up, boy.
♪ You are starting
to piss me off.
♪ Take your hands off that girl.
You have already had enough.
♪ Hey, shut the fuck up boy.
♪ You are starting
to piss me off.
♪ Take your hands
off that girl,
♪ you have already had enough.
>> PETER: ♪ It's getting
hard to see,
♪ for all our history.
♪ I guess it's
in your blood,
♪ on that we can agree.
♪ And when we saw her face,
♪ I said she's something else.
♪ She was your only hope,
♪ and still you let her down.
♪ You just can't lay it down.
♪ You just gonna lay her down.
>> JOHN: ♪ Hey, shut
the fuck up, boy.
♪ You are starting
to piss me off.
♪ Take your hands
off that girl.
♪ You have already had enough.
>> PETER BJORN and JOHN: ♪ Hey, shut the fuck up, boy.
♪ You are starting
to piss me off.
♪ Take your hands off
that girl.
♪ You have already
had enough.
♪ Hey, shut the fuck up, boy.
♪ You are starting
to piss me off.
♪ Take your hands
off that girl.
♪ You have already had enough.
>> PETER: ♪ Ah...
♪ Ah...
♪ Ah... ♪
[clapping]
>> BJORN: Australia.
>> JOHN: Anymore questions
from the audience
or someone else?
With anyone else?
Good.
Apart from yesterday,
it's all being really good,
much better than
we expected.
We thought we will have like,
what you call it?
>> BJORN: Hard tool.
>> JOHN: Hardwire, yeah,
glued to our instruments
and like bottles thrown
at us or something,
but being the opposite, actually.
Yeah.
Help me.
>> BJORN: Yeah, we're
going to do that after.
He was an ace after.
It was just a joke but...
>> JOHN: No, it wasn't--
okay. But...
>> PETER: Give us some now.
>> BJORN: Yeah.
>> JOHN: Yeah.
>> PETER: More questions?
Oh.
>> What it was like
to sing in English?
>> PETER: You know, when
you are five-six years old,
it didn't--
we never decided,
it's just everyone listens to
American and English
music in Sweden,
and we learn English
in school from nine--
from nine years old, so.
We see a lot of American TV,
you know.
You know, I never thought
about it really.
But of course
in the beginning,
you couldn't do proper lyrics,
so it was more,
"Why they go..."
like a cowboy language.
I
don't know.
It's a bit fair now.
>> JOHN: Yeah.
And your question,
what band we would like to
tour with except Depeche Mode.
I will--I think I
would take Van Halen.
[laugher]
Yeah.
Sorry.
>> PETER: More questions?
Yeah.
>> JOHN: Remixing?
>> BJORN: Remixing music.
I'll have the CI, that's you
in the Google shirt.
You get that for free?
Remixing music,
that's--
it's too easy now,
but it's still very
hard to get it right,
I think,
you know, like many things now.
And apart from that,
I don't think anything
about that.
>> PETER: Some of the remixes
are really good,
some are not so good,
more are not so good, but,
you know,
it's [indistinct] who do it,
so it's fine.
Yes.
>> BJORN: Drake, yeah,
the artist, Drake.
He bought the record,
I hope,
and then he used to work on it because he liked it, I guess.
So, we didn't hear it until it was finished and then we said,
"Okay, this is good.
It's a good one.
You got some good lyrics
going there, Drake.
So you might as well put it
out on your official mix tape
or album maybe or"--
I don't know really what is.
I think it's like a mixed-tape
on an album.
He put it out on now,
so, yeah.
We like that.
>> PETER: Yup.
>> Maybe we should change...
>> JOHN: Yeah.
>> PETER: I don't know, maybe we should change the next record.
JOHN: We tried to make it as close to Peter, Paul and Mary,
since I'm not to marry yet.
I might fix that, yeah.
So, then it should have been
Peter, Bjorn, and Johnny,
Johnny, yeah. Okay.
>> BJORN: Yeah.
>> JOHN: Spill out, yeah,
that's, you know--
questions?
Yeah
>> How did you guys
find each other?
>> PETER: We all been
playing separately
since we were super small
by ourselves and
with other people,
but this band has been going
on for 10 years now,
so it's our 10th anniversary.
Before that--yeah.
Thank you.
Before that, me and Bjorn
had some other projects.
But we had to get John to make
something happening out of it.
So, yeah, I don't know how
we found each other really,
but there was no one else
to play with I guess,
so we had to stick
with each other.
>> BJORN: Actually, we put the--this--one of these notes up on--
in a music shop,
but that didn't
work out that well.
Maybe, you didn't-- you've never had to meet those persons,
John, so but you're lucky.
>> JOHN: No, I put up--
I also put up,
but it didn't happen.
Yeah.
>> BJORN: Yeah, thank you.
>> PETER: Anything else?
Yeah.
This year, 2009?
It's a Swedish album by a guy called Existence Minimum (ph),
which is very, very good.
It's hard to explain,
but it means like you don't
have anything to live out of,
minimum of existence,
I guess.
So Google that,
it's a great album,
it should be released
over here, I think.
And I like The Pains of
Being Pure at Heart,
I think it's a good record.
And what else came out
this year?
>> BJORN: Usually the stuff
came out the year before,
but the Empire of the Sun maybe
didn't meet last year--
I don't know.
But it's really good one.
Empire of the Sun.
Thank you.
>> JOHN: It was last year,
but you should check out
Jenny Wilson, Wilson--
Jenny Wilson,
a Swedish,
good singer--
singers, woman,
friend, and mother.
>> PETER: Not John's mother.
>> JOHN: No.
>> PETER: Yet. But some
other great Swedish artist
that we're going to tour with
in November over here
at Sura El Spring,
El Perro Del Mar (ph),
and she's going to open for
us in November in station.
She's got a really good new
record called Love Is Not Pop,
which I think is really good.
>> BJORN: So, she'll be coming here, right, San Francisco?
>> PETER: Yeah, I think so.
Come to that show.
>> JOHN: Yeah.
>> So check out Swedish rules. >> JOHN: Paper.
>> PETER: Swedish
medical paper.
There's another Swedish
band called Bear Quartet.
It's coming out
with a new record, so.
>> Yeah.
>> PETER: They've
been around since '91.
They got like 15 albums
out or something
and most of them
are really good.
So, they want to tour here,
they told,
and have too many kids.
But get their albums
from somewhere.
I don't know how
to get from here,
but web--the Web, yeah?
>> JOHN: Internet?
>> PETER: Internet? Yeah.
>>Yeah,when you guys tour here in November, you know--?
>> PETER: Well, you have to eat,
that's very important.
And I learned something
for the past year that--
and Bjorn has known
for a long time
that you shouldn't go
and walk around
and try to look for the best
restaurant if you're hungry,
just take the closest one.
And if it's shit--
I mean,
get something in your
stomach and keeps you sane.
So--because we're kind
of picky about food,
but you can't always pick.
And in San Francisco,
we've been so happy so far.
I just walk around the block
and it's all pretty good,
so it's a good city.
And apart from that,
just walking around,
go to museums and...
>> BJORN: Yeah. But
the problem on tour--
if you have not been
on a tour--
I don't know--
is that you feel like you're
not doing anything like, so,
you're not like really
supposed to get anything to eat
because you didn't do anything
because you sat on
a bus or, you know,
talk to some people or
played on Google or,
you know, I didn't--
we didn't really, you know--
so hours just pass
by and then you
kind of forget to eat,
so eat.
It's good.
>> PETER: Yeah.
>> Have you guys
tried the Yahoo?
>> PETER: What's that?
>> Have you guys tried Yahoo?
>> BJORN: Yup?
>> Y-L-T
>> PETER: Jupe (ph).
>> Yahoo.
>> PETER: Yahoo?
>> So Yahoo is a Website that helps you find good restaurant.
>> PETER: Uh-huh.
>> Uh-huh.
>> BJORN: No
>> PETER: Yeah.
>> BJORN: With wherever you are? >> PETER: Nope.
>> Nope?
>> PETER: Nope,
you should try that.
>> BJORN: Yeah. Or asking someone, you know.
>> PETER: Yeah.
>> BJORN: It's good too.
>> PETER: Like, old school way.
>> JOHN: Respect.
>> [INDISTINCT]
album [INDISTINCT]?
>> PETER: Yeah, there's
some poo in my post mail
and like old fish and stuff.
So it wasn't very nice,
but and we sort
that out and--yeah.
It's important
to do other stuff.
We all do separate projects.
And that's also part
of keeping you sane
when you've been in
a band for so long,
and you also have
the time to do it.
Before, we had other jobs
or other things to do,
so you only had time
for maybe this project.
But now, there's lots of time.
People think you're
busy all the time,
and you are, but it's
your own fault, so...
>> Yeah.
>> PETER: Yeah.
Yep
>> So, what do you think
of your country being
called a socialist
stronghold (ph).
>> PETER: Say's who?
>> BJORN: We got no
problem with that.
>> PETER: Who says that?
You says that? No?
>> PETER: Oh, okay.
Yeah.
>> BJORN: I like it.
>> PETER: I don't like
socialists, so...
>> BJORN: Not being in hell,
so--but--yeah. Yeah.
You think nothing
about that, actually.
We're economists, yeah.
>> PETER: Yeah?
We are.
You should try it.
>> BJORN: Yeah.
>> JOHN: Okay.
>> BJORN: No.
>> PETER: Questions?
>> PETER: Yeah.
>> BJORN: Yeah, it works.
This song is from an EP
that we put out in Sweden
on Flown Economy (ph) that's--
yeah, check that on the net too,
Flown Economy (ph) that we put it out on the Falling Out album,
extra material not here
maybe though.
Is it out here?
Well, in Europe,
so it's, anyway,
available on somewhere.
And this is called
I Just Wanna See Through.
>> PETER: ♪ And now, I see
they're screaming harder,
♪ and they're throwing things.
♪ But I don't want to follow,
♪ I don't need to follow.
♪ I'm trying to get hollow,
♪ trying to get hollow.
♪ Is there something
I can borrow,
♪ just until tomorrow?
♪ And now I see
they're getting lamer
♪ to the point of lying down.
♪ The beat is getting softer,
♪ the heat is getting colder.
♪ The light is getting dimmer,
♪ substance getting thinner.
♪ But I'm still
trying to grasp it.
♪ They gave me
meals to choke on.
♪ And now you hold his hand,
♪ now he understands.
♪ But I don't have to face it.
♪ I don't have to chase shit.
♪ I just wanna see-through,
♪ I want to embrace you.
♪ Get back where you
belong at university.
♪ Or try to do it our way,
♪ try to make it this way.
♪ But I don't need to listen.
♪ I'll be home for Christmas.
♪ I'll see you
when it's raining,
♪ when society is draining.
♪ You'll be up and you'll be
down in a matter of minutes.
♪ I've tried to run
the distance,
♪ tried to jump the high fence.
♪ But I've never
been a sportsman,
♪ got picked last
when they picked teams.
♪ I'm the worst
kind of amateur,
♪ the kind which
never wins the war.
♪ Though I had the best
of teachers,
♪ they called me the seeker.
♪ And now you,
♪ and now you hold his hand.
♪ Now he understands.
♪ But I don't have to face it.
♪ I don't have to chase shit.
♪ Oh, 'cause I just
wanna see-through.
>> PETER AND BJORN: ♪ I
want to embrace you.
♪ I just wanna see-through,
♪ I want to embrace you.
♪ Oh, oh, oh.
♪ I just wanna see-through,
♪ I want to embrace you.
♪ You... ♪
[clapping]
>> BJORN: Thank you so much.
Thanks for coming
out in this room.
Thank you so much.